companies are driven by money
so putting a price on carbon emissions
should encourage businesses to stop
polluting right
that's exactly what carbon markets were
designed to do
reduce emissions by charging polluters
but so far they haven't achieved that
aim here's why
[Music]
towards the end of the 1980s america had
a problem
for years its power stations have been
emitting large amounts of sulfur dioxide
which is falling back to earth as acid
rain
causing harm to plants aquatic animals
and infrastructure
but there was no incentive for the power
plants to stop emitting sulfur dioxide
weather warnings an acid rain alert is
in effect
so in 1990 the american government
launched an experiment
passing a law to force polluters to pay
for their emissions by establishing a
new kind of market
governed by a system called cap and
trade
eight years later
acid rain levels over large regions in
eastern america have fallen by 20
percent
and a new way of cutting emissions was
born
in 1997
the international climate change treaty
known as the kyoto protocol suggested
applying the concept of cap and trade to
carbon
in the years that followed different
countries and regions set up their own
carbon markets
many of these use cap and trade
and this is how it works
a government sets a cap on the amount of
co2 that can be emitted by an industry
it splits the cap into permits and
either gives or sells these permits to
firms
if a company doesn't use up all of its
allowance it can sell what it doesn't
need
if it needs more permits it can buy them
from those with spares each year the cat
gets stricter and the shrinking pool of
permits gets more expensive
the genius of cap and trade systems when
they're done properly
is that
they both use a stick
and a carrot
that gives them an incentive to innovate
to get cleaner and cleaner it provides
that carrot for innovation and that
trading mechanism the magic of the
market unleashes those animal spirits in
favor of decarbonization
while regulation can introduce a new
industry standard
it doesn't give firms an incentive to
cut emissions below a certain level
but a carbon market creates a race in
which companies are motivated to cut
emissions as fast as they can
the more they cut emissions the fewer
permits they have to buy and the more
excess they have to sell
[Music]
so in theory in a cap and trade market
carbon dioxide emissions should fall
but in reality they've continued to rise
because incentives only work if they're
big enough
carbon markets are great in theory
but in practice
we run into a problem carbon prices have
been far too low to motivate change
that's needed to decarbonize the world
economy
according to joseph stiglitz and
nicholas stern two economists in order
to meet the paris agreement goal of
limiting global warming to two degrees
above pre-industrial levels
the price of carbon worldwide needs to
be between 50 and 100 per ton by 2030
however the majority of carbon prices
still remain far below that figure
what's more
even if carbon is priced appropriately
the fines for exceeding permitted levels
are sometimes ineffectively low
in the eu a fine could be as low as 100
euros per excess ton
considering that's not much more than
the price of a permit it's hardly a
deterrent and that's if firms even get
caught
now in theory
regulators enforce carbon prices and
permits but in practice it can be very
challenging there is measurement
problems direct emissions versus
indirect emissions
there's questions of cheating for
example you find in most markets around
the world enforcement is lacks and
punishment is not great and even if some
markets adopt effective deterrence the
ones next door may not
if you look globally you have
mind-boggling variety of rules systems
enforcement mechanisms and so if you're
a company that's based in multiple
countries divisions of your company
making the same product in the same way
will face a mind-boggling patchwork of
rules regulations that differ
worse than that you have leakage among
these markets as well
the direct result of this patchwork of
systems is known as carbon leakage
a business or an industry relocates from
an area with high environmental
regulations to somewhere where the rules
are more relaxed
which means it can avoid having to pay
for its carbon emissions
but these problems have solutions
the role of regulation is important
because absent regulation nobody would
pay for carbon emissions or pay a
penalty for emitting carbon so almost by
definition government has to create the
market
set the rules enforce penalties set a
carbon cap for example the maximum
amount a company or industry can emit
if governments limited the number of
permits it would drive that price up
setting a minimum price that rises over
time would mean the price would never
fall too low
and governments can enforce more
stringent deterrence for potential rule
breakers
getting serious about regulating carbon
markets really involves regulators
making it clear to industry that they
will not tolerate cheating they will not
tolerate leakage or obfuscation
and ultimately that they will hold
corporate executives to account for
their carbon emissions i think we're
getting there particularly in the
european union we're seeing much more
seriousness that this is not a frivolous
green washing exercise nudge-nudge
wink-wink but rather that this is as
serious as safety or other regulations
this is not yet the case in many other
parts of the world
it would help if the world had more
integrated carbon markets
but as that's unlikely to happen in the
short term one solution to help prevent
carbon leakage is a border tax
the eu has recently proposed to tax the
carbon emitted in goods produced outside
its carbon market
importers would have to pay the same
amount as if the goods have been made in
the eu meaning it wouldn't be any
cheaper to source goods from a region
with less regulation
if we're going to get serious about
dealing with climate change
within the next few years we must
achieve something like a global carbon
price and some form of harmonization
amongst economies now we're getting to
something like momentum in this
direction the big kahuna is china
because it's such a industrial
powerhouse it's so carbon intensive if
it doesn't get serious and work with
other economies to harmonize carbon
pricing and carbon trading systems then
most of the world's efforts will
probably be undermined by the fact that
countries like china are producing
heavily carbon intensive goods and we'll
see multinationals shifting production
to those places even more than they have
in the past
[Music]
as climate change has moved up the
political agenda governments are
starting to improve how their carbon
markets work
since 2019 the eu has been taking steps
to reduce the number of permits it hands
out
partly as a result carbon prices in the
eu are now hitting record highs of over
60 euros per tonne
carbon prices in other markets are also
rising as regulators look at ways to
make them more effective
if it seems that money can be made other
countries might create their own markets
we have seen just in the last 12 to 18
months a dramatic
takeoff in carbon markets this is
a really exciting time for people who
believe
that there is a good marriage between
public policy and regulators and markets
and innovators
if prices stay high enough
helped by commitments from governments
and regulators then greener industrial
processes would become more attractive
and carbon markets could start to
achieve their original goal of helping
to decarbonize the world
i'm vijay badis warren the economist
global energy and climate innovation
editor
to keep up to date with all of our
climate change coverage
please click on the link
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]
you